gentlemen there is a war raging right
now with the Magisterium between those
trying to keep us in ignorance and those
willing to fight for truth and freedom
who will stand with me this kind of
heresy is with highest priority to the
Magisterium I need to know where he's
going and what he intends to achieve
John snake the North is no place for a
child
the Masters asked if I can find a place
for you and I want you as my assistant
you're an explorer too just like my
uncle I can teach you to wield power you
must let me magic we believe there is an
organization to the stealing children
and taking north
sometimes
[Music]
I promise to do everything I could to
protect you from harm
it's an elite the orbiter it is illegal
unless approved by the Magisterium tells
you the truth
she has to make a journey one which I'm
afraid includes a great betrayal
it's trying to move something
I suspect it's trying to warn you away
he scores me
[Music]
I can fly your questions should I be
asking you that we are not Magisterium
madam I would ask where I could obtain
services of an armored bear Yorick
Benson
people need our help Yorick let's go
give
it's time
[Music]
[Music]
you